let's talk about Buffalo Bill's safety
tomorrow Hamlin we are hearing him speak
for the first time since he collapsed
from a cardiac arrest during game this
month Hamlin posted a nearly six minute
video on social media over the weekend
thanking the medical staff who saved his
life and the people who have been
rooting for his recovery watch this
as it was just a lot to process within
my own self mentally physically even
spiritually it's just been about the
process but I can't tell you how
appreciative I am of all the love all
the support and everything that's just
been coming in my way
Hamlin is recovering at home and
continuing rehab with the bills I love
that he's talking about I do telling us
what he's going through so many people
still cheering for him cheering for him
and he says that in a way that what
happened to him is a way that he's going
to be able to use that to make people's
lives better especially young people we
talk about how passionate he's always
been even before he got into the NFL
about helping young people and he feels
that this is a way to do that we all
just want to be okay absolutely